I'm an office manager for a small
construction company and
um one of the owners out of the two has
been using a secret credit card and
purchasing a lot of purchase personal
stuff with it and then using the
companies checking to pay off the
balance each month I'm just kind of
curious is it only
um morally wrong if I don't say anything
to the owner other owner or um is it not
my none of my business to be passing
information along
so let me help you with how you answer a
business ethics question
treat other people
like you'd want to be treated
so reverse it
you own a construction company and you
have an employee
who knows that there is a thief
inside the business
what would you expect that employee to
do ethically